oh
thank you for your patience we were
having some audio difficulties uh but
we're here now with uh Lieutenant
Colonel Prem bass uh who crevass who is
uh going to be leading our session today
please bear with me for just a second
more as I start our live streaming
for our LinkedIn live audience and that
will take me just about 20 seconds
and
all right and Welcome to our LinkedIn
live audience our YouTube live streaming
audience and also to everyone here on
our WebEx Channel
we are so
glad you're here and thank you for your
patience as we got our technical issues
resolved
and welcome to this career master class
on how to build a winning resume
Lieutenant Colonel canvas
CEO Provence Ventures
for people on the WebEx
uh Channel please put your questions for
pram into the Q a box
and we'll get to those in the Q a
section of the webinar toward the end uh
you can also chat to all panelists but
where that um we may not be looking at
the chat all the time because we're
being in the conversation uh so to
introduce Prem I'm going to let him
speak about himself
and tell you about Prem 100 Ventures and
um
his expertise in
career coaching
okay
thank you so much to it it's great
always to be with uh simply learn and
this is a very good opportunity for most
of you to get Advantage the value out of
the experience that I've had so I've
been in the uh in the career profession
for about 35 years out of which 21 and a
half has been in the arm Armed Forces so
that's how I'm at Legend kernel and
thereafter about 15 years as chief of
operations and head of HR in four
different Industries
and uh I've been able to you know gather
a lot of experience out of that by
virtue of these appointments and by
being a Management Consultant and
finally today I am an ICF coach ACC
associate certified coach today and
that's how I am capitalizing myself on
the experience that I've gained to share
it with among you all so today's
session
yeah
I'm going to um let's get our polling
together wonderful but do you want me to
let you share your screen so that you
can present your materials I'll do that
uh so here we go you have to give me
access oh
hold on a second
and there you go
okay
please let me know if you can see the
screen
yes
okay
I was just rehearsing when all of a
sudden yeah there we are
okay great so you had a sneak peek of
what I'm planning to you know for all of
you ahead all right so I was at this
introduction and I want to wish each one
of you a very good morning a good
afternoon and a good evening depending
on which part of the world you are and
uh so some of the things that I before
we start the session quickly uh we
thankfully just lost about five minutes
so I'll try and make up for the time uh
firstly I would like you to understand
that
this is stitched from my experience some
facts of course I've taken from the
internet but more of it is the
experience so you may not find some of
the content here so stay within the last
and while we are at the webinar please
go ahead and give your comments your
emotions so that I know uh where I am
clicking and I can monitor accountingly
and now we will go into the poll because
I want to understand the audience and so
let's keep it interactive after that and
shall I go ahead with the poll uh stud
yes please
okay this is the first poll the audience
poll uh which country are you attending
from if you could mention that
and in the poll you can go ahead and
answer the second question as well
yeah the second question talks about how
many years of experience do you have as
a student less than five years between
five to ten years and more than 10 years
and then just type in your country into
the uh
blank area
so great
and we'll keep the poll open for another
five seconds yes we'll do that it's
quite an easy question so
here we go
so I will share with you
oh
go ahead yeah so we have a very uh
balanced audience here students about 25
percent more than 10 years about 27
percent and between five and five to ten
we have the remaining uh portion okay
very balanced crowd great so I uh the
presentation is going to hold good for
everyone now thanks for that let's go to
the next question
and
yes what is your experience in creating
a resume today just want to understand
that I'm gonna have one maybe you had
once or maybe two or three times more
than three times it could be either on
your own or you could have got help from
stuff whatever it is just your
experience in creating resumes
we'll keep this just open for another 10
seconds before I close it yep
foreign
and never about 12 percent which is
fairly uh good because the content also
addresses them and more than three times
about 30 percent so roughly two to
thirty three times is about 66 percent
okay great but you can go to the next
comp a question what is your experience
in Korea that's one we have just
finished with that we go to the third
one
yeah so this talks about
your preference in creating a resume
going into the question
yes we're going into the question just a
second here yeah
there we go
Prince Paul there it is yeah so what is
your preference in creating a resume is
it self preparation or do you take help
from a friend in your company or your
industry
or do you use an online resume design
portal or would you be hiring a resume
consultant
take your choice
so
we have about 15 seconds more
excellent so self-repression is most of
this this is definitely going to this
webinar is going to benefit you because
that is where you're going to be there
45 percent of you on self-propriation
and hiring a resume consumer is hardly
seven percent right and taking help from
friends is about 17 percent and yes
online is good so let's go with the
audience poll number four this is the
last of the poll that we have
so what according to you is the most
common reason and this is the most
important question that we have what
according to you is the most common
reason for resume
okay getting rejected for interview
shortlisting
so please go ahead and
choose your option and only one option
and another 10 seconds or so yes
all right
oh yes this is us
as expected my resume content yes that's
the one which is uh not matching right
and uh yeah the resume does not match
with the job description 46 percent of
you got it right and that's amazing
because that's what is expected and
using one standard yes that is another
big clue that you have given that
standard one and this is 77 percent of
you have got it right let's go to the uh
presentation proper thanks a lot for
guiding us through this uh polls to it
thank you you're welcome
okay so so let's go to the presentation
proper now
so what to expect from this session so
this is what we are going to see the
content is and uh difference between a
resume and a CV so I find that there is
a little bit of uh you know an overlap
people taking a resume and a CV
interchanging it one for the other so
we'll we'll see what is a subtle
difference there then what are the
formats and types of resumes so and how
do you choose them the resume structure
and the content so that how do you
structure it and the content so that it
cuts through the Clutter the role of
application tracking software a lot of
us are not aware how the system is
working and I'll take you through this
the nuances of this so that you are
going to create winning
resumes based on these aspects the
nuances of a covering letter what goes
into a covering letter and a video
resume this is what something which is
happening of late the video resume not
entirely a resume switch because you
can't put all the information there in
that but it supplements your resume
which you wanna you may have submitted
so what we will also take a look at what
is this video resume and of course how
can I help as a coach and as an inventor
in your journey of creating your next
opportunity in your career and then
we'll follow it up with a question and
succession so I'll try and close this
for about 30 minutes so that we have
enough time for the question answer
session that's where we get so I'll
request Stuart to keep track of that
because I'm going to concentrate exactly
on the presentation
so resume is inevitable for a working
profession
see earlier we had we used to work for
companies till the time you were perhaps
one or company maybe another one so we
used to make our our presentation sorry
our resume just the beginning and maybe
after a graduation and that's the end of
it today the scene is entirely different
today we are likely to change your jobs
at least every six second or third time
minimum before you retire so therefore
resume is going to part of every
transition from one job to another
so it is going to be part of you so you
better be good at that it's as simple as
that so to do that what are the aspects
so I'm only going to cover that we have
a very uh restricted time going to make
every second useful so please take your
screenshots for you information that you
got and you can take your notes right
the CV versus resume I thought I must
touch this because uh this is what is
important today and uh
the CV that is curriculum video is
Origins Latin of course this is just uh
academic and the resume is from French
the length of the CV runs from two to
three pages nowadays even it's getting
even less people put a full stop at two
pages three pages only in case you have
a senior or your an academics and you
need to go for senior roles and that's
where you it goes for about three pages
otherwise two pages is a full stop
similarly a resume has to be a one page
it cannot go beyond a page this is a no
okay then the freshers Juniors people
were up to five to seven years they are
the ones who would have their content
filled up in a resume senior roles
definitely will have more information so
it goes into a CV and it's targeted for
Carrier profiling that is the curriculum
beta and the resume goes for your work
expectations targeted for specific job
openings right Civic takes your whole
carrier into consideration and the
resume goes for specific kill or a job
that you're applying for
and it's referred as as a resume in UK
Ireland and European countries in USA
they might ask you for a resume or a CV
it's it's either this or that and
Austria and South Africa they use both
as a synonym
some companies in India and Bangladesh
especially the pus that is the public
sector units and the government
departments ask for a biodata biodata is
and it's it's almost history but still
the institution and the and the content
of a biodata is different from a CBR
resume so having understood this let's
go and so there's one more thing which I
want to tell you which you would notice
that in resume I'm not using the tilde
or the the mark apostrophe which comes
after e you are not required to use it
you can use resume the way that it is
all those the best clue for you is that
in case if the company was asking for
your resume if they're using it then you
can use it otherwise you can go with the
word the way with the way as it is
resuming
okay a resume reflects your induency can
you quickly say a yes or a no on this I
just want to take a look at that how
quickly one can just reflect your as or
no oh wonderful yes it reflects your
personality I'm yet to see a no
great absolutely you guys are bang on
the dot resume because
a lot of people
try and do a cut-based job of your
resume if you do a cut paste then it is
not reflecting your personality it's not
reflecting your individuality as long as
you have a structure in place and fill
in your information it reflects your
individuality
it showcases your professional identity
and your and your behavioral identity
comes or gets reflected in the
interviews this is functional aspect of
your professional what you've been
through what you've done is what comes
in the in the resume therefore it is
reflecting your personality right and
therefore right like I told you no
cut-based job it will not come and a
very seasoned HR person can see through
this I can see through a cut-based
interview sorry resume in just about
five to six seconds
that that's because and I can't say how
it comes because of experience your
resume gives out your functional
experience that is why it it's it is has
to reflect your functional individuality
as to what you did in the past of that
resume
your ability to take on a job role is
determined by the interview process
called behavioral event interviews this
is a subject by itself so I do work I
can do a webinar on this itself now
behavioral event reviews tells me or a
candidate about the candidate to the
interviewer as to how would you react in
a situation because you are going to
deal with people you are going to deal
with the teams you are going to deal
with customers on all those jobs on all
those roles we would like to know how
are you going to deal with the situation
so this is they will ask you questions
on a past to see how are you responding
to it that will give out your
personality this will not come out in
your resume it comes only in the
interview
and they might give you a future want to
see a hypothetical one to see how do you
respond to that right
you have to justify your resume during
interviews with real life examples so
every word every bullet point that you
put into your resume has some story to
tell about it right it can just go about
two or three minutes not beyond that but
just have a story so that it tells you
about your reflecting of individuality
which was talking about your personal
what you did so that is why it's so
important to do that some of the
important elements of your resume this
is standard okay every across the globe
these aspects has to come out in a
resume
your name email ID Mobile number or a
LinkedIn and your LinkedIn should have
your link hyperlinked in that resume
it's very important nobody is going to
go and look and paste and all of that
they're not going to look for you in the
LinkedIn LinkedIn same name there will
be hundreds in your first name so
therefore have your LinkedIn hyperlinked
in your resume very important okay and
the key competence or skill sets this
has to come in the beginning and the key
educational qualifications your
professional course that if you happen
to be a student your projects the events
that you have done hyperlink hyperlink
means it is uh you know you click on
that link and then if you go down to the
uh the uh the menu the drop down menu
you will find there a hyperlink and when
you click on that it will take that link
of your LinkedIn profile so that when
somebody clicks on that it takes
straight into LinkedIn profile directly
they don't have to go and search that is
what is hyperlink about and
these four aspects
your key education qualifications
professional courses projects events
depending on whether you're student or
your in uh you know early stages of a
career or mid carrier that will come in
Reverse chronology that is the latest
will come first and then the others and
your employment history if you've been
working then Employment industry if you
are a student what all you have done as
a student that comes there first okay
all both of this has to be in Reverse
technology right the latest one first
and then it goes down
the reason is and and of course is your
bullet points it don't put a running
test nobody nobody's got patience to
read for running tests they would like
to see and highlight some of the
important words in that bullet points
which is important okay and your awards
and achievements they have to come out
if you've got them please bring out
something out there because it speaks
high of your proficiency your competence
now
next these are the other aspects which
come into the the resume the language
proficiency the hobbies and the interest
this can be optional depending on the
space the real estate of your one page
of your resume and then this is
sensitive info you need not diverges
then your religion your gender your
photo and your date of birth unless the
company asks you to give you that
information right your gender your photo
and your date of birth if date of birth
some in U.S companies they would not
like you to mention your date of birth
and they are very sensitive about
dni so therefore new diversity and
inclusion is very important so your
gender shouldn't come there neither your
photograph needs to come there the
resume gets rejected straight away so be
careful about this in case of Doubt get
back to the company and check with them
or check with somebody in the HR in the
company to make sure your CV resume does
not get rejected because of these
reasons right and then reference on
requests and signatures it's fussy it
was there earlier number of days because
you're all on the on emails now they're
legal enough so therefore uh you don't
have to sign it and uh references again
nobody mentions it because the
background verification uh teams are
there for the companies who do that for
you and secondly after the resumes have
been gone through your interviews are
done and once they're going to select
you perhaps that is the time when the
shortlisting is happening that they
might reach out to you to ask for a
reference
you're likely to have gaps the pandemic
is perhaps one of the biggest reasons
for that please give short notes to
cover the gaps don't allow them to
reject your resume because you didn't
explain that Gap anything more than six
months is again so give that reason for
that and be honest a very short note
about it right because the background
verification organizations they will
pick out the Gap and it will not good
look good for you if they find out that
what you said and what is actually the
reason is is not the same
I continuously update your resume every
six months you must update your resume
with the latest something that should
happen because memory is short you will
forget some of the data that comes into
your resume so you must do that do not
lie I'm just repeating again
formats of resume what are the kind of
formats of resume this is academic but
they you're important to know
chronological resume that is reverse
chronology what I said let's say if
you're 7 10 15 20 years of experience
you've gone through various stages of it
so that preferably has to be a
chronological resume various stages of
your career must mention that and some
of the highlights don't go more than
three to four bullet points there
maximum okay and then comes your
functional or your skill based resume so
if you are this is for people who are
much more senior and they have more
functions to talk about put only the
functions you don't have to mention you
can just say my career profile and just
in one paragraph various timelines of
what you were doing and how you grew up
in that in your career so that is all
that will come there and that's purely
on the skills that you have and a combo
is when you have a combination of both
which you can be you can choose suppose
you feel there are certain aspects of
your career that you need to highlight
light as a functional highlight put that
as functional portion of it and rest of
it as a combo portion that is your
chronological portion targeted resume is
let's say you're going to your most of
us have switched over our jobs into a
gig economy so we are part of a gig
employee and therefore we might be
taking on Special Projects so therefore
that must have a targeted resume for the
project that you're applying for so
that's why it's called a targeted
receiver okay
yeah I'll be sharing this resume I'll
give you an oversight of this right I'm
I'm deliberately not sharing that
example in a in a very detailed form
because a lot of you are coming from
across your various job profiles and
things will not be fair but I will show
you uh the important aspects of the type
of resume so you first have a text
resume and then you have something
called a visual or a two-dimensional
resume
and the third thing is the infographic
or a three-dimensional I'll take you
through an example this is what I'll
show you in the next few slides an
example of how these resumes look like
and why each is important where okay now
this is how a text resume looks like
right to solve your text this is the one
which most of you must go because your
eight years which I will talk again on
the ATS portion of the webinar this is
this is the one which gives you purely
text the ATS can read text
more of it when we go into it as to why
I'm insisting on why texture is remain
right this is a two-dimensional uh
resume and just share this with you uh
you see this one this particular
gentleman has given out whatever his
networking skills in forms of an icon he
he didn't mention that as words he
mentioned as icons here and what he is
you could see here what he's mentioned
is all the uh what do you call uh Awards
and recognition that you got over the
years I'm not able to show this very
clearly but just understand the whole of
it because that is what I want you to
get the bird's eye view of what a
two-dimensional one is now the
the three-dimensional one is just one
second
just a moment please
yeah the three dimensional one is
something like this which has not of
infographics and the graphics and if you
see in this see there are timelines
given now here you see he's given his
core competences in in various uh what
you call so she actually gave this like
this because it's got when we really
don't know what is this rating that this
particular graph is mentioning and the
technical skills all is done very good
or she's done very good for herself but
the technical skills has given some kind
of a graph which I'm not able to explain
or can't understand so this looks very
good it looks very impressive but the
ATS cannot read this this will be reject
there
so my take for you on this both it's
two-dimensional or the third this the
infographic one if you're going to
create because you love them please use
it only when you're using it as a hard
copy when you're going for the interview
you can have it it might look impressive
and that's it but if it is going through
the digital mode do not use the second
or the third one that is the two
dimensional or the three dimensional
three-dimensional of the infographic one
okay
right now choosing the right resume what
are the choices chronological or versus
hybrid hybrid is the one which I was
talking about where there's such
chronological as well as the functional
portion that's a hybrid that is
something which depends on what kind of
a carrier have you done you can always
reach out to me I will share my
coordinates in this presentation and
I'll tell you how which is a better bet
for you how do you do that right and
then the simple text resume which is the
most important and the most popular one
that you should use and then you have
the visual or the infographic one for
the digital submission you should avoid
it for digital submissions you must have
a hard copy if you must otherwise if
you're going to go to the LinkedIn and
upload your CV only use text resume if
you're going to send it as an email if
you're going to send it as in the
website if you're going to register in
the website of the company in the
carrier side and if you're going to
upload it make sure it is a text resume
and not a visual or infographic one
okay use of application tracking system
the 80s and I'm going to refer this as
ATS and
the reason why ATS
75 75 to 88 percent resumes are not
qualified for the job amazing isn't it
as a recruiter you would any of you who
are recruiters you realize that let's
say if there are 200 applications coming
for a particular job profile 150 of them
are not qualified because everybody
sends like most of us do just shoot out
your application hoping that you know
your resume might get selected whereas
you're not even bothered to find out
whether the resume is aligned to the job
description that has been given or the
job rule that you're looking for so just
imagine if somebody has to go to 200
manually and if they have to reject 150
look at the amount of time they have
this is one of the reasons why you need
an automated system and that is an
application tracking system there are
about 15 or 12 to 15 odd ones across the
globe various companies use it now you
do not know which application they are
using some of these applications is
possible that they might read uh
infographics and but again you do not
know which company is using what
application
some of the application tracking system
the eight years made the Vintage is
older they can only read text they
cannot read tables I'll text again about
this so they cannot read that is why
your text is simple text one is what are
the aspects that goes into it I will
touch upon this so now you understood
why a company so just imagine a
recruiter with 10 profiles we ask of for
the profiles to come for in this resume
to come from them and even if it's
minimum 300 just imagine
that's three thousand is it humanly
possible for that person to go and look
at that and this is again a reason why
they say that a resume once it comes to
even after going through the eight years
they do not spend more than seven to
eight seconds they say that's an average
not everybody does it that way but
that's an average so do you see how your
resume the first half and the first
portion of your register the first page
the first half is all that they may have
to look at to decide whether they should
call for an interview or not so that's a
kind of problem so what is it actually
so all your resumes goes into this
application tracking software it then
the job description is then tuned to
accept what percentage of match there
are keywords there is
a percentage that the recruiter can fix
on the system and the system passes
through all the resumes whether it comes
through uh online or to the portal or to
LinkedIn and then it picks out only the
ones that gives the match that the
application tracking system has been
designated for and then it comes for
further calling for the interviews so
you see the probability how it reduces
in case if thousands of applications
come for a single post it happens
usually at the lower levels of the at
the junior levels or at the levels of
say the interns and freshers very high
percentage of applications and you have
very high chances of yours getting
rejected if you don't align your your
resume to the job description so here
are some facts for you Kelly ocg survey
did this about to three years back 98
percent of Fortune 500 companies use 80s
and 66 percent large companies and 35
percent small and medium Enterprises
now the sad part is well this is a good
figure to understand you do not know
which company is using or not using so
therefore you can't take a chance okay
so
what are the nuances of trying to get
your probability of getting your C
resume
accepted for the next call that is the
interview
you need to ask for the job description
the job description will tell you what
they're looking for in you so at least
so that you're able to match your you're
not lying you're not stating a wrong
statement you're only picking up what
you are qualified for from the job
description and changing your resume
accordingly okay so every JD should have
its own linked resume so if you're going
to apply for 10 jobs you must have 10
business
you can't have one single like you most
of you answered very nicely in that poll
if you have a standard CV sending out
for for your jobs you will definitely
get it rejected it just unlock
then an application tracking algorithm
or specific keywords that I already
touched upon to you include metrics
every word that you say should be able
that is how when you include better use
node facts because I'll give you
examples shortly when you include all of
that that shows particularly as to how
individual you are how personalized your
resumes okay and avoid tables columns
graphs pie charts images it can't read
and even if if some latest
you know they use the company uses it
and if and which you have no idea about
don't take the chance
use reverse chronology for Education
quality because it is also designed to
read it that way okay so abbreviations
should be spelled out because some of
the qualifications you might have done
it but the person or who's reading it
may not be aware of it so always use
abbreviations only after you've spelled
it out initially and thereafter you can
repeat it professional experience versus
my expertise in German this is just to
give an example let's say in your resume
you wanted to use my Expedition General
I mean you are a very flamboyant guy so
you wanted to use that but if the job
description says that they're looking
for your professional experience it's
strongly recommend that you replace my
expertise in general with professional
experience
as long as you can keep matching this it
will be better for you you increase your
probability of your of your resume
getting
shortlisted
okay keep the resume under one mega bar
it's this is this is this is basically
to uh you know you don't eat up the uh
the space that the company has got is
just a matter of courtesy so Tranquility
you can always do this okay
okay I'll quickly answer the questions
if you are in using infographics because
you are 90 companies and all of that
then if you're I'm not sure whether the
company that you're applying for is also
using the uh infographics as one of the
ATS which can read that please check
that and then send it so that answers
that question there leave one inch of
margin space all around the resume it
should not be less than 0.5 inch because
that's how it is designed and avoid
content in the headers and Footers some
can read some can read again so why
avoid it because you do not know what is
the ATS track software that can read or
cannot read That's why recommended fonts
I just put the fonts away it is these
are the fonts some of them which can
come up and which can be read the
difference is let's say some of the
fonts if you use the artistic ones the
fancy ones you can't read whether it is
five or whether it's a numerical five or
it's a letter s right so if you say
you've increased something by 50 percent
right it might read that s0 also and not
read that at all so if it is a fancy
letter that you use so that fact that
you want to mention does not get read so
it's that important your font size
should be anything between 10 to 12
points because that's what I said and
avoid fancy colors and icons
I'm just repeating so that you just
click it in your mind word art doesn't
help at all only these fonts that is
given here check for grammar and
spelling mistake this is a big big put
off this grammar and spelling mistakes
you they're all the softwares that come
there now your operating systems they
all have it otherwise you can always go
in for a grammar and spelling app right
I won't be able to recommend here
because for obvious reasons this is not
a commercial filler so therefore you
will have to look for yourself and ask
people to get that no scan document or
scanned image remember I told you that
atheists only reads text
so if you made a CV sorry resume and you
took a photograph of that on your mobile
and then if you upload it into the thing
into the email or on the on the site it
will not read it it just your CV just as
good as it's getting not read at all
this it will reject it straight away
because it's a scanned document it can't
read the text what's written there okay
so it's very important that you notice
this right use docx that is uh and and a
PDF these two are the accepted ones no
uh JPEG and any of that that's not going
to read okay it's get rejected so take a
screenshot of this these are important
aspects that you must keep when making
your resume okay some common mistakes
just wanted to take you through that and
uh
you know like for instance created
models to structure you see the too much
of space spacing is not right you've
introduced uh you're not you you're used
to the wrong plural there and then uh
the full stop either you have full stops
all across your resume or you don't have
it at all right so have uniformity there
and then you know got your spellings
wrong and then you got your tense wrong
it should be preferably in past tense
and third person do not use first person
uh that is what is generally acceptable
there may be some people who would want
to use first person and that's your
individual choice but generally people
expect you to do a third person and like
for instance you know mistakes like not
capitalizing the first let me know so
this is just to give you an experience
so always use spelling grammar checking
tools before submitting the resume right
and metrics is to describe the magnitude
of what you do I'll just give you an
example of how if you just write and
what's the difference when I mentioned
that magnitude of what you do
normally you would find was responsible
for delivery of all client projects with
excellence
no man or beast understands this
what delivery what all plans which
project and what do you mean by
Excellence Your Excellence may not be
what the interviewer or the the
recruiter's Excellence so it would be
better if you put it with facts and
figures like this executed 18 months
dollar 40 million upgradation product
project within 16 months with net
promoter score of 8.7 out of 10.
very clearly telling you what exactly
you did and it tells you what a great
guy you are
right the first one in red will not tell
you that but the second one the way that
you put it will tell you what you've
done it shows the magnitude of what
you've done
now cost saving initiatives this is for
uh another example a cost saving
initiative most of us have to you know
go through this was instrumental in
Saving cost and inventory management
okay now
very generic I really can't make much
out of this but if I say like this
reduced Inventory management costs by 22
percent and how by optimizing stock
turnover using Innovative digital
initiatives now this speaks about what
I'm capable of right
right recognition about
you know in recognition also you really
some people feel very humble about it
please remember that your resume is
actually your sales
tool so you have to say something about
what your Awards and recognition is
recommended for on-site transfer at
client locations abroad for attaining
third position in the company's top 10
high performance employees chart very
specific very clearly what's that you
can always prove it because this is
something which will get also perhaps
verified in your background verification
check qualification certification there
must be a sequence when you put it as as
we always said it should be pronounced
in the reverse chronology but it must
have what is the course that you did
where did you do it which is the
Institute you did from and preferably
the month and the year which you did the
Vintage of many children this is a
sequence you must follow okay
the cover letter now cover letter slowly
going out of fashion but still some
companies insist that you send a cover
letter so what is this coverlet about
and it's basically an elevator pitch of
your resume right and usually it's also
accompanied by civilian some people
insist on it I just thought I'll share
some facts with you
you know 26 percent of recruiters
consider them critical right and 56
percent want a cover letter to be
attached which opines that it gives a
boost of your resume so this is why some
people might insist that you send a
cover letter okay so it is better to use
a cover letter when you accompany your
email resume especially
when you have templates like for
instance when you have to upload it into
the company website or the LinkedIn uh
job profiles when you have to upload it
uh there may be no option for you to
upload a cover letter so which is fine
but if there is an option it will
specifically ask you for it in which
case you need to make a cover letter and
attach to it if you're sending to
somebody specifically because somebody
asked you to as a referral then if
you're sending it your resume there then
you could add a cover letter to it okay
now what goes into a cover letter just
remember this take a screenshot of this
because this is what your cover letter
this is like your elevator pitch right
why should they hire you it should
answer this question
and it should and when you answer this
question basically three paragraphs
should mention this the first one
paragraph should say what is so good
about your combination of your skill and
their experience that meets the job
description
then keep it crisp as to why is this
profile exciting to you yes that you
have to keep it profile okay that why is
it exciting and make it very specific to
you something that you enjoy doing it
you can't lie here because it will get
caught in your interview and the third
one
how can you be
contributed to the future of the company
so focus on how you can add value to the
Future in the job role that you're going
to take on if you cover this then
generally your cover letter is likely to
be a great one right prefer addressing
by name if you can get all the name of
the person say instead of saying Dear Mr
HR manager or dear recruiter you can
always say dear and the person's name
you know Miss or Mr or first name as it
is because nowadays again gender you
really don't know you can't make out a
gender so the first name is fine so
that's how you have to go ahead with
your uh addressing preferably but if you
don't have it for some reason which
sometimes is the case it's okay if you
just say about the appointment because
you would have got the cover letter or
sorry the the job description from
someone so if you could mention that as
a appointment that's also good enough
lastly make a special if you have some
special Connections in there please
mention that in your cover letter whom
do you know at what appointment this is
very good and it is going to help you
clinch better because those the people
if it gets selected for a short listing
they will definitely reach out to them
to understand about you and there is an
accepted fact that 83 to 85 percent of
the jobs in the middle and the higher
levels are only through reference
so one in sorry eight in ten persons or
more than eight in ten persons can get a
job only if they are referred
so therefore if you have somebody they
do mention about it LinkedIn is the best
source for you to connect with if you go
to if somebody is there in that and if
you are sending an application reach out
to that connector of yours and tell them
you have done that see if they can use
refer them in your cover letter please
do that and increase your chances of
getting shortlisted
at all costs avoid sounding desperate
your problems in life is your problem
it's not the company's problem
okay so I might sound harsh here but the
truth is do not sound desperate just
because you were not having a job or you
got a family running and your blah blah
blah the video resume okay it
supplements the resume or the cover
letter unless if they ask you for a
video resume what should it contain
Your Entertainment customer care
Marketing sales professional these are
the ones who usually ask you for a video
resume right it adds to the resume that
you read and it should at an average go
between 30 seconds to two minutes 30
seconds is because your shots YouTube
shots is about that much and two minutes
is because Instagram is about 1.3 uh
minutes so roughly two minutes don't go
beyond that nobody's got the patience to
go read through it if the resume can be
read only in 78 seconds uh they're doing
a big deal by going through your video
for about 30 seconds or a little more
than that so just keep it to that much
prepare your script when you do the
video video dress professionally very
important okay and there's no shortcut
you don't go by the argument I mean
they're select me for the job role that
I'm playing I mean water is just got to
do it it's fine for an argument it's
fine for a conversation it's not fine
for getting selected or getting the
probability of getting a shortlisted
okay so take a call
watch your posture when you're recording
let's let's see you know your posture
should be positive your shoulders square
and take it from your chest above and
you don't have to stand and then do your
video unless the the entertainment
industry wants a video of you standing
okay ensure professional background and
lighting obviously this is their good
lighting get it done professionally
through somebody who have studio if you
if it is possible that's the best and
record multiple takes and select the one
clip that you find you're very
comfortable with right and only you can
decide that
and finally I did the video for
Christmas and brevity very important if
30 seconds matter then every second in
that recording matter so have it edited
right so now how can I be of help and
this is how I can be I do a as a coach
and a mentor I do a 20 minute 30 minutes
when you reach out to me to find out how
you can help you out and what advisory
that I can while preparing a resume this
is something that I will help you out
for one hour I do a session on this one
this would be a paid one and a designing
a resume for an ATS contact
compatibility this will be on the need
based if you want it done or if you have
somebody you can do it yourself but I
have a panel of Consultants who do this
and this takes about a LinkedIn
optimization takes about one to one and
a half hours because that's important
because most of your resume content and
probability increases by the use of
LinkedIn in the content of your resume
that's why I talked about it and if you
wish to be preparing for the interview I
do a one hour session or a mark into
using the feedback after that right so
take a screenshot of this this is my
contact number I'm on WhatsApp as well
as telegram on this number so please
read more on WhatsApp and this is my
email ID so you can reach out on this
right this is again my coordinates you
can take if you've got a smartphone you
click this this is my digital card on
this digital card you will get all that
I do my my credentials my profile my
testimonials all of that is there and
here is my mobile number and the and the
coordinates I've also got my website
which is leadership with bus I've also
got a YouTube channel all of this you
will get to know from this my YouTube
channel has got a lot of content on
Career enhancement okay and this is how
if you click on the digital query any of
this if you could click it will take you
to details of what it is this is just to
give you an example of how it can be
done now I go to the question answer
sessions I've managed to do it within 40
minutes
uh maybe we may have to shoot by about
five minutes but Stuart I'll leave that
to you from Simply learn can we go out
with the questions I have not been able
to keep the track of the questions
because concentrating on fetching this
yeah absolutely
um so we have several questions about
LinkedIn
um is it mandatory and does it have to
match your resume
yes uh so this question is good because
uh your resume is for one page where is
your res if in the in the LinkedIn it's
got more space more real estate for you
to put in your information so you can
say your resume can be an extract of
your LinkedIn information because each
tenure of yours you can put in 2000
words there so that will that means that
there's more content there somebody goes
into LinkedIn they'd get to know more
about you and Linkedin also gives you a
lot of other information features like
your recommendations your endorsements
it talks a lot of that what is your
groups that you are there and what are
your contributions and how so it talks
about your blog a lot of things which
cannot come in a resume so that resume
that you're having there you can also
upload your resume or a CV there but
you're each CV each resume thereafter is
aligned to the job description of the
job that you're applying for so
therefore that difference will always
remain yeah next question
um you mentioned that you should not
include a date of birth a picture what
was the other thing that you mentioned
yes I did mention that because uh some
of the companies have a policy that they
they are very specific about uh dni that
this diversity and inclusion and they do
not want to know the gender so therefore
no photographs and date of birth because
again they're looking at their
competence and not uh you know how uh
how old are you this is especially where
dni where veterans and all are being
recruited because they want more to know
about what your capability competence is
so that's why
Rahul asked the question what's the
effect of a gap in your resume on
selection
uh sorry I I just missed that question
oh
what effect does a gap in your resume or
your in your employment uh okay
do to your chances of being selected see
well one of the reasons uh the the Gap
is that they they wanted to wonder what
have you done in that Gap why are you
without unemployment that's the reason
they want to ask and uh is it because
you lost the previous job and you were
not able to get another one uh is one of
the minus ways or the negative way of
looking at why you are having the Gap
the positive way of looking at the Gap
is perhaps you have taken a sabbatical
to upgrade your skill if you want to you
know you you've gone done a specialized
course during that time or the pandemic
itself is a gap by itself you know a lot
of us lost our jobs because of that all
for the day for the women it could be a
maternity or it could be taking care of
somebody who is critically ill all of
those reasons can be they just mentioned
that so that they know what is the
reason why the Gap is there all of us
are human beings we can understand where
somebody is going through a problem
right but don't resign out of Bad Blood
and then say that you know you are
looking after your mother during the
time it will come out through the
background verification don't lie there
that's all right
thank you
pardon me
apologize
one moment
excuse me hello
and he held something wrong
um if you're a fresher okay what are the
things you should emphasize when you
don't have a lot of
actual job experience absolutely this is
the case with most of us right who are
freshers precious interns and obviously
we all know that you don't have a job
experience so the best thing what you
can do is that uh the job description
for freshers will be aligned to what
you've done in your academics okay what
your what you've learned so therefore
don't worry about it the the best way
for you to do is to include in your
resume what are they looking for in the
job role and how you were able to
achieve that in your for instance if
they're looking at somebody who's very
good at communications skills because
it's a customer role I'm just giving an
example so if you can put in your resume
as a fresher that you know you have uh
handled uh say fundraising with across
uh the uh spectrum of people customers
and you've been able to race about say
some x amount of money because of your
ability to convince people that talks
about your ability to communicate that's
the kind of information that you should
put which is aligned to the job
description
thank you um
we have a question about uh should you
include your certification details in
your resume and a related question I'll
follow up
but go ahead
uh yeah so you must uh you must include
those those things in your resume uh the
question is whether you should include
all of it or what is relevant is that
the one that he's asking
um
is just asking should we include
certification details in the resume and
the follow-up I was going to ask this
question because it's telling uh
certification course with simply learn
in a different field
um
so what would they include as proof of
capability for their new field
okay
okay so let me answer this question this
way see uh your resume is of one page so
there is very less real estate there for
you to add all the certifications that
you may have done so it is best to align
your certifications and the
qualifications which justifies the job
role that you're doing
so if you have done about 10
certifications and if the job role is
speaking about analytics there's no
points mentioning about you know you can
mention about uh you you can definitely
say about Excel some business analytics
roles that certificates that you've done
but there's no point in saying that on
public speaking you have done uh course
certificate it doesn't gel with that
particular thing so select what is
relevant to the job role and put in only
that
that makes sense
um
we have a question about how to keep
everything on one page as you gain more
experience and how many projects can you
include in a one-page resume okay damn
good question I'm I'm this is something
which most of us have a challenge with
and that's a challenge and a wonderful
Challenge and ultimately how to handle
this okay it's very exciting when you do
this remember the job description is
telling you they're looking at some XYZ
in you now you must just put only that
information of your recent past suppose
if you are of 25 years of experience no
point talking about something about 20
years back they want to know in the job
role because you are reached that much
higher level so they want to know in the
job role what is the current thing that
you have done and how did you go about
it align to the job description that
they're given so if include only that is
good enough so maybe for the past 10
years whatever we have done you include
that that will definitely will come
within the job description sorry in the
20 shows that you're talking about in
The Experience history the earlier
portion you can just
met all what was the appointment
designation which company and which time
that's it and call it as initial
experience and leave it at that
um
question here about people who are
transitioning from one career field to
another petite guess what are the
important things to mention and to to
leave out when you're doing that
transition
okay so firstly when you're doing a
transition obviously you may have done
and uh you would have done enough
Skilling or a certification or something
to go into the transition okay that's
one so that definitely needs to find a
mention in your uh resume the second
thing is that in the new role that
you're going to do some of the aspects
is by virtue of your experience when you
are in the earlier career will
definitely find way for instance certain
aspects of leadership I'll just take an
example of a veteran for example so a
veteran is doing a contents agency
operations for instance now extreme high
levels of leadership involves their
planning execution operational feedback
and all of that is that's part of that
now if he is going into a corporate
world where he's going to supply chain
management for instance so in Supply
Chain management you have a very high
level of pressure high level of use of
data you have so you have to be updating
what is happening exactly every now and
then so this is a skill set that you can
match for the supply chain that you're
doing so that's how you bring out what
aspect of that you did so you can say
that you know your operationally you did
this much and your levels of success
have increased with this percentage is
because of having analyzed so many
things that's how you change that
language into what your new career
transition is happening for instance
and I hope that addresses the questions
from Nishi Kumar and uh live now because
they were all doing transitions um
basic question
um but if you are applying for the same
role to different organizations do you
still revise the resume for each one
okay so it uh the resume is actually
aligned to the job description
so each of the company will have it's
obviously a different version of a job
description it won't be the same so you
need to align it with a job description
the importance is the job description
okay and that's why it is different it
will be different
okay you also mentioned um a functional
experience resume versus a cut cut and
paste job resume and could you just
elaborate a little bit on what those are
okay so a functional resume is like for
instance let's say you have been uh your
uh you function as a uh a lead okay in
business analytics so let's say that is
a function that you did and you've been
doing it for the past say 15 years so
you grew up you started as a team member
finally you're a team lead and now you
are a project manager okay so now that
is a functional role that you've done
the last five and five to six years you
would have done as a functional that's a
functional rule so you that is what all
have you done in that role as a project
management that is your functional role
now if you're looking at the uh if you
want to mention about something that
happened when you were a lead or when
you were a team lead then that will come
as a chronology one which is where you
would mention I said you must have done
something very particular there
something you want to highlight
something you want which is aligned to
the job description event so you will
mention that in one or two bullet points
so now there is this is a combination
difference between a functional one and
a chronological one and if you can
combine both of them because it
highlights your experience and your
capability that is called a hybrid
resume
and and my understanding of uh when you
when you advise against cut and taste
resumes that means don't just take text
out of your master copy of your resume
put it into a new document without
editing it or tailoring it to the to a
job description for the thing you're
actually applying for is that is that
accurate yeah absolutely it's true
that's that's very very right and also
the other way around you know I get hold
of two three uh resumes from my friends
and somebody and then you know borrowed
from there and then cut paste and make
one for myself
yeah
that's that's one of the dangers of and
we hope that you will be able to share
some sample resume formats but the thing
we caution is that don't just cut and
paste anything out of those samples
because
um it's those are just samples of how to
format not examples of what the content
should be
um and when you talk about highlighting
experience or highlighting something in
your resume do you literally mean to use
like a yellow highlight or a bold font
of that type of thing or are you simply
talking about wording it so that it's
good question good question see uh when
you highlight uh what I meant was to
make it bold
uh because the atheists can read text it
can't read your highlight
it's not going to understand your
highlight which color it is and what it
is yes the same text uh resume if you
want to take it for an interview to show
it to them as a reference then perhaps
if you want to use colors there YouTube
use highlights there then it stands out
it is it has to be a hard copy where it
can get reflected for an atheist it
doesn't really uh you know make sense if
you make it bold it is only just that it
it's a text that gets highlighted that's
about
um that's vasudevan asks uh if you're
sending a resume by physical mail by a
snail mail hard copy again uh should you
use the 2D or 3D formats or should you
still stay with the text format
uh if you're sending it uh I think then
you can definitely take the risk of
sending it by uh by the two dimensional
or the two dimensional one uh if you're
very sure that it that CV is going to be
taken the way that it is and nobody is
going to put that into an ATS if Jamaica
if the HR of that takes you gets it from
the pole they can still put it through
an atheist
okay if they do that
then the CV will get
so it's always better like I mentioned
earlier too it's always better to when
you're going physically for an interview
take these two D's on the 3D ones and if
you're sending it to someone keep it to
a text one safer
thank you
um last question I'm going to take
because we have run over time but the
last question is regarding cover letters
do they help or if they're listed as
optional are they really mandatory or
are they truly optional and don't
necessarily help you okay so uh cover
letter uh like I like I mentioned uh is
going uh out of uh fashion these days
unless you are sending it to somebody uh
as an email a direct email where it is
an attachment then the body of that
email will be sort of a cover letter
second aspect of a cover letter is when
the company asks you in their website or
on the LinkedIn they say that apart from
your resume they are also requesting you
to send a cover letter in that case you
need to create an assassin so they just
do different documents okay
yeah so if you have any more questions
please shoot out to me in this feedback
that I've got I've shared my mobile
number as well as my uh ring and of
course uh Stuart I'm sure simply alone
has also got a feedback right from where
they can reach out to you too yes and
we'll be sending a follow-up email to
everybody uh in this stuff and so we
will include with that
um a link to the session recording and
if you would send me the slides I can
also send them a PDF of the slides not
the PowerPoint because it's proprietary
to you but I can send them a PDF of
presentation with all of your
information and with that let me go
ahead
go to the last part of their webinar
close it out in the last couple of
minutes
and
sorry okay we have one last Poll for the
audience and this is um
for
people to think about what skills and
tools you want to add in a
session like this you're obviously
thinking about Career Development Career
changes
um along with that what type of skills
do you want to add to your
personal toolkit
personal capabilities
it's just for our
reference
but open for another 15 seconds or so
and we mentioned these particular skills
because these are the types of skills
that simply learn offers certification
in
oh
and I'll close the poll
now
so we have uh interest in business and
project management as the most common
and then
data science AI cloud computing follow
that a little bit of interest in each of
these things so this is good and again
um
about
30 of the audience says they'd like to
get started right away so we'll uh
let's quickly share with you a little
bit about that so that um as as you're
we were thanking pram I guess we want to
put I want to put into the chat
quick message
oops
yeah excuse me
and this quick message for the audience
uh
gives you the link to our website
which I'm sure that
scene but also this gives us
there we go
the email address asked us at
simplylearn.net is um
finished here
again I've put into the chat all of
these links so you have those available
to you just look in the chat and
will be done and
you can connect with us at simply learn
on
Facebook on Twitter on LinkedIn or some
company name simply learn so we look
forward to keeping in touch with you uh
thank you again Prem for for this
excellent excellent session
um and
we hope to see all of you in the
audience at Future simply learn webinars
and hopefully we can welcome you into
the simply learned Learning Community as
well so
take care and this concludes our webinar
for today